yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
like many fans I thought gal gadot
--tz-- Wonder Woman really kicked ass on
the big screen in Batman V Superman and
with this year marking the 75th
anniversary of the first appearance of
Wonder Woman
aka Dyna prints in All Star Comics
number eight and with her first
live-action solo movie coming out next
year I wanted to take a look at five
cool facts you need to know about gal
gadot --tz--
Wonder Woman when creating winter
woman's new costume the designers wanted
to ensure it reflected the fact she's
been around for thousands of years
costume designer Michael Wilkinson drew
on gladiator and warrior influences for
the breastplate split skirt and armor
initially Zack Snyder wanted her costume
too made from metal however this was
impractical as Wonder Woman stunt
sequences and choreography require her
to be able to move with ease in the end
the costume designers developed material
that looked metallic but still allowed
for flexibility of movement and the
breastplate was designed with expansion
joints that allow gal gadot to breathe
and perform her stunt moves more easily
to finish the costume it was given a
distressed feel with sword cuts and
Nick's to show centuries of were from
battle Wonder Woman's Eagle motif
appears throughout her costume weapons
and new logo you can see the Eagle in
her breastplate but you might not have
spotted the Eagle symbol engraved into
the upper part of her sword there's also
an Eagle emblem in the center of her
shield although in Batman V Superman
it's hardly visible as the shield is
very old and the Eagle emblems been worn
down from use in battle just like
Superman's hidden Kryptonian quote in
his suit when the woman's sword and
shield also contained encrypted quote by
American author Joseph Campbell the
quote was translated by a linguist into
a hybrid extinct language and is
engraved into the swords blade and
around the rim of the shield the quote
is from camels book goddesses mystery of
the feminine divine and reads life is
killing life all the time and so the
goddess kills herself in the sacrifice
of her own animal for Wonder Woman's
iconoclasm the designers used a
distressed 20-foot gold braid her bells
has a quick-release attachment so she
can access the lasso and it also
contains a fiber-optic cable which
lights up and serves as a reference to
the VFX team to enhance the lasas look
in previous incarnations of window woman
this particular weapon is often called
the lasso of
truth and anyone caught in it can be
forced to speak truthfully although we
didn't see this capability in Batman V
Superman Zack Snyder has confirmed that
the LA Zoo can do that
although gal gadot already had some
combat training having served in the
Israeli army she still had to undertake
a demanding training program to
transform herself into the iconic super
heroine she worked with fitness trainer
mocked white over seven months and
trained in sword and shield play as well
as a range of martial arts such as kung
foo kickboxing capoeira and jujitsu
according to guards she progressed
through the training she noticed how she
started to stand and sit differently and
how satisfying it was to transform into
something new so guys what did you think
of gal gadot as Wonder Woman in Batman V
Superman and what are you most looking
forward to seeing her solo movie I'd
love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below if you enjoyed this video
do please like share and subscribe and
also check out my DC movies playlist
with videos including 10 amazing deleted
scenes from Batman V Superman and WTF
facts about Suicide Squad you can check
out any of those in the links below
thanks for watching and see you next
time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers